senator joe manchin announces he is done
with build back better the radical left
goes insane over it and oh macron panic
continues despite non-scary numbers i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
[Music]
show this show is sponsored by
expressvpn it's time to stand up to big
tech protect your data at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment and much news there is first
if you are looking for a way to help
your budget this holiday season i have a
great way to do that that would be a
pure talk usa you're spending a lot of
money on gifts aren't you well what if
you could save on a gift and also just
be saving overall that's where pure talk
usa comes in pure talk has iphone 12
starting just 479 bucks through the end
of the year they even have 13s as well i
switch to pure talk i'm getting great
nationwide 5g coverage the same coverage
as the big guys and you can too the
average family saves over 800 a year now
that's just the smart thing to do i
wouldn't tell you to use a service i'm
not completely happy with you should
make the switch the way i did with
peertalk's 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose you got a
limited talk text six gigs of data just
30 bucks a month and as i said that
iphone 12 is just 479
so go to puretalk.com shop for the
planet phone that's right for you then
enter promo code shapiro save an
additional 50 off your very first month
and save on a new phone that is
puretalk.com promo code shapiro puretalk
is simply smarter wireless some
restrictions apply seaside for details
once again go to peertalk.com shop for
that plan and phone right for you enter
promo code shapiro save 50 off your
first month and save on a new phone at
the same time already so over the
weekend joe biden's dreams died so you
have to get the world's tiniest violin
out for the world's most feeble
president the president of the united
states had been hoping that he would be
able to follow the bernie sanders path
toward glory and it was always
politically bewildering he didn't have
the support for this there are 50 votes
in the senate from the right
there are 50 votes in the senate that
are democratic and there are at least
two of those votes that are not really
of the hard left because kirsten cinema
from arizona is in a very purple state
she barely won her last race and joe
manchin is from a state that is redder
than red a state that donald trump won
by a 40-point margin and so the notion
that joe biden was going to be able to
with that sort of majority like 50 plus
kamala harris is the highbreaker rammed
through a bernie sanders agenda was
completely delusional and it is
absolutely bewildering as to why joe
biden ever thought that this was going
to happen this is the part that's
totally crazy to me i do not understand
for the life of me why joe biden thought
that he could shift from the
quote-unquote moderate he was supposed
to be into an fdr lbj type and nobody
would notice and that all of the people
in the center would just go right along
with it
you know how far did joe biden shift he
went from being the guy who defeated
bernie sanders because the entire
democratic party base mobilized against
bernie sanders so the guy mirroring
bernie sanders priorities you know i
just noticed the other day
so the time 100 had joe biden on it
right you know who wrote joe biden's
piece for the time 100 bernie
it was bernie who's writing joe biden's
piece which is amazing i mean it really
is it's as though george w bush had been
elected and then the most right-wing
senator in the united states had written
a piece about how george w bush was
mirroring all of his priorities bernie
sanders is a radical kook bernie sanders
is a socialistic idiot bernie sanders is
a full-scale commie okay and bernie
sanders despite his protestations that
he likes scandinavia not the ussr bernie
sanders is the guy pushing the most
radical agenda in the senate and he's
the one writing joe biden's time 100
profile this year
and here is what bernie sanders wrote
quote
biden's bold american rescue plan
created a strong vaccine program that
will save tens of thousands of lives
alleviate hunger and homelessness reduce
the child poverty rate by more than half
help revitalize the economy now through
two unprecedented pieces of legislation
the infrastructure bill and the budget
resolution he's leading the effort to
create millions of good paying jobs et
cetera et cetera i look forward to
working with president biden on these
transformative efforts but here's the
thing no one was going to do this
particularly nacho mansion
and joe manchin was never hiding at the
ball he was never hiding the ball
back in july joe manchin made chuck
schumer the senate majority leader sign
a letter that letter listed his actual
priorities okay he was not hiding the
ball
he said that any revenue exceeding 1.5
trillion would be used for deficit
reduction the corporate tax rate would
not rise above 25
the corporate domestic minimum tax would
be 15
he said that the the only bill that he
would that he would sign on to would be
a 1.5 trillion top line bill without
budget gimmicks
right he said that there would be
spending on innovation not elimination
with regard to climate change that is
not what joe biden was proposing
he suggested there would be targeted
spending caps on existing programs no
additional handouts or transfer payments
right so there's tons of stuff that he
forced chuck schumer to sign on to and
then everybody in the media act
surprised that joe manchin sucked by the
deal that he signed with chuck schumer
okay so over the weekend joe manchin
announced to much fanfare that he was a
no on this thing he was on fox news and
of course he of course he was a no he's
been to know for months on this thing he
has no political incentive to sign on
with the president who's currently
riding at 41 in the approval ratings and
in joe manchin's home state joe biden is
running in the negatives i mean like
there are people who have not yet been
born in west virginia who say they don't
like joe biden at this point
so here is joe manchin
saying what anybody who watched politics
knew for a while which is that this bill
was was never going anywhere
when you have these things coming at you
the way they are right now i've always
said this brett
if i can't go home and explain it
to the people of west virginia i can't
vote for it
and i cannot vote to continue with this
piece of legislation i just can't i've
tried everything humanly possible i
can't get there you're done this is this
is a no
this is a no
okay and um and the entire media are
just bewildered how could this have
happened it must have been that there
was some sort of break in the
relationship between joe manchin and and
joe biden no there was no break in the
relationship the relationship never
really existed is your problem guys
so joe manchin put out a a full
statement explaining his position
we'll get to that in in just one second
first
let's talk about your business needs
okay so the fact is that right now
there's like 10 million open jobs in the
united states only 7 million people
willing to fill those jobs which means
if you're an employer you need workers
you need employees and that means you
need to find the best employees the best
way to do that head on over to zip
recruiter their invite to apply feature
lets you invite the best candidates to
apply for your open roles and now you
can try it for free at zip recruiter.com
dailywire how does invite to apply work
well when you post a job on zip
recruiter you start getting the most
qualified people sent to you pretty
quickly then you can easily review
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply with one click next
key marketing manager aaron hartree
loves invite to apply she says they get
my job posting in front of the right
people i instantly see great candidates
and i can invite them to apply to my job
in fact according to zip recruiter
internal data on average for 2020 jobs
where employers use zip recruiters
invite to apply get two and a half times
more candidates which helps make for a
faster hiring process you can see it for
yourself just go to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire to try zip recruiter for free
that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-ire zip recruiter.com
zipper is indeed the smartest way to
hire alrighty here is the statement for
five and a half months i've worked as
diligently as possible meeting with
president biden majority leader schumer
speaker pelosi and my colleagues on
every end of the political spectrum to
determine the best path forward despite
my serious reservations
i've made my concerns clear through
public statements op-eds and private
conversations my concerns have only
increased as the pandemic surges on
inflation rises and geopolitical
uncertainty increases around the world
i've always said if i can't go back home
and explain it i can't vote for it
despite my best efforts i cannot explain
bill back better in west virginia i
cannot vote to move forward on this
mammoth piece of legislation
joe manchin continues my democratic
colleagues in washington are determined
to dramatically reshape our society in a
way that leaves our country even more
vulnerable to the threats we face i
cannot take that risk with a staggering
debt of more than 29 trillion dollars
and inflation taxes that are real and
harmful to every hard-working american
at the gas pump grocery store and
utility bills with no end in sight
the american people deserve transparency
on the true cost of the buildback better
act the nonpartisan congressional budget
office determined the cost is upwards of
4.5 trillion dollars which is more than
double what the bills are in supporters
have claimed they continue to camouflage
the real cost of the intent behind this
bill
as the omicron variant spreads
throughout communities across the
country we are seeing covet 19 cases
rise at rates we have not seen since the
height of the pandemic we're also facing
increasing geopolitical uncertainty as
tensions rise with both russia and china
says senator manchin our ability to
quickly and effectively respond to these
pending threats would be drastically
hindered by our rising debt if enacted
the bill would also risk the reliability
of our electric grid and increase our
dependence on foreign supply chains the
energy transition my colleagues seek is
already well underway in the united
states of america in the last two years
as chairman of the senate energy and
natural resources committee and with
bipartisan support we've invested
billions of dollars into clean energy
technologies so we can continue to lead
the world in reducing emissions through
renovation but to do so at a rate that
is faster than technology or the markets
allow will have catastrophic
consequences for the american people
like we have seen in both texas and
california in the last two years i will
never forget the warning from then
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
admiral mike mullen that he delivered
during a senate armed services committee
hearing during my first year in the
senate
he testified the greatest threat facing
our nation was our national debt and
since that time our debt has doubled i
will continue working with my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle to address
the needs of all americans and do so in
a way that does not risk our nation's
independence security and way of life
right that is the statement put out by
joe manchin so inflation
and national debt and misplaced
priorities and really bottom line the
fact that if he votes for this thing
he's toast and he knows he's dosed if he
sides with joe biden in west virginia he
does not have a senate seat anymore in
four years everyone knows this he knows
this
hey but the media are trying to make
this out to be a personality issue
between joe manchin and july it's not a
personality issue
the incentive structure was completely
wrong and joe biden was delusional and
the progressives were delusional if they
thought they were going to get joe biden
on board by the way kirsten cinema
apparently is going around telling
people that she and manchin are
stand-ins for half a dozen other
democratic senators who are in purple
states and who are looking around going
man i'm glad that i didn't have to vote
on that piece of crap
according to politico last night less
than 30 minutes before he killed the
democratic party's most important piece
of legislation an aide was dispatched by
senator joe manchin to give the white
house and congressional leadership a
heads up the senator himself was about
to go live and was prepping for his
interview with bret baer on fox news
sunday
he was out of town with family and doing
the hit via satellite says politico he
wore a red tie and pinstripe suit his
hair looked perfect it would probably be
one of the most viral video clips of his
long career at the white house there was
panic and disbelief he sent an aide to
tell the president of the united states
he was about to go on fox news and put a
bullet and build back better
well yeah i mean guys because you've
been completely ignoring what he's been
saying the whole time he said it from
day one and then you guys pretended
because you live in your own heads that
joe manchin was just gonna do what you
wanted him to do
this is why nancy pelosi kept scheduling
votes on this thing and then having to
cancel votes on this thing it's why
chuck schumer kept saying we're going to
do it by ex-date nope well actually
we'll do it by this day nope well
actually we'll just move they're going
to keep doing this top white house
officials scramble to call senator
manchin and talk him out of what he was
about to do
we tried to head him off a senior white
house official told playbook manchin
refused to take a call from the white
house staff
at fox news's washington studio bear was
hosting his first episode of fox news
sunday since chris wallace abruptly
decamped the show's staff knew how much
attention would be on them and how
important it was in the ongoing war
between news and opinion to prove the
news side could still drive a
conversation
manchin did not give bear a heads up
about the news he was about to break
okay so then they quote mansion
okay bottom line is that the entire
white house is very upset
so gensaki came out and slammed senator
manchin
accusing joe manchin of betrayal
the white house put out a statement
saying on tuesday of this week senator
manchin came to the white house and
submitted to the president in person
directly a written outline for a build
that better bill that was the same size
and scope as the president's framework
and covered many of the same priorities
while that framework was missing key
priorities we believed it could lead to
a compromise acceptable to all senator
manchin promised to continue
conversations in the days ahead and to
work with us to reach that common ground
if his comments on fox had written a
statement indicating ends that effort
they represent a sudden and inexplicable
reversal in his position and a breach of
his commitments to the president and the
senator's colleagues in the house and
senate
by the way this signals that the white
house knows it's over because if the
white house really thought there was a
path forward for negotiation
here's what you don't do set joe manchin
on fire right if you're joe biden and
you want to negotiate with that guy you
cannot douse him in gasoline and light a
match and yet that's what the white
house is doing right there the white
house puts out a statement saying that
it's a betrayal a sudden an inexplicable
reversal in his that's not true
you guys just refused to sense the
reality
everyone knew what was going to happen
here you guys are just crazy now
i will point out here that there is a a
belief among some senate republicans
that this justifies the infrastructure
plan the reason is because joe manchin
got the infrastructure bill he wanted
the infrastructure bill mitt romney rob
portman the deal that they made
essentially with mansion and cinema is
we will do the infrastructure bill with
you but you will not to build back
better a giant boondoggle spending bill
where all of the priorities that were
cut out of the infrastructure bill then
get stuffed into the buildback better
act
and there are worries about trust right
the mansion in cinema would cave and
that they would then vote for build back
better as well as the infrastructure
bill and the democrats would get all
their spending so we will have to point
out here that the strategic move made by
some of these guys in the senate to put
forward the infrastructure bill as sort
of a stop to mansion and cinema to keep
them from restructuring the entire
american economy was not necessarily the
worst strategic move now it's possible
that if they'd not passed the
infrastructure bill they still wouldn't
have gotten bill back better because the
incentives would be no different
it would still have been a hard slog to
get buildback better approved by the
voters of west virginia that said the
baseline notion that you could get
mansion in cinema to kill build back
better if you gave them infrastructure
that turned out at least to be true in
the sense that buildback better is now
dead
senior white house official is ripping
on mansion says look with mansion you
never know i've never seen anything like
this the guy shook hands to the
president he made us a written offer on
tuesday that had holes but was doable if
he flipped away from that so quickly
maybe he can flip back
yeah i i think not i really really think
not
and we'll get to more of this in just
one second and what does this mean it
means two things one joe biden is not
going to be the president he wanted to
be
and two
counter-intuitively joe manchin might
have just saved joe biden's presidency
i'll explain in just a second first
we've got a very different kind of
sponsor for this episode the jordan
harbinger show it's a podcast you really
should be listening to i know that every
day somebody tells you you just have to
listen to some podcasts you're not you
say sure and then you forget about it
but jordan's show really is a great
lesson apple named it one of its best of
2018 it's aimed at making you a better
informed more critical thinker so you
can get a sense of how the world
actually works and come to your own
conclusions about what's happening even
inside your own brain each episode is a
conversation with a different
fascinating guest when i say there's
something for everyone i really mean
that in one episode jordan talks to a
hostage negotiator from the fbi who
offers techniques on how to get people
to like and trust you which sounds
useful and disturbing at the same time
another episode tells the story of a
pimp and mafia enforcer who talks about
mind manipulation techniques and how you
can defend against them every
conversation is really worth listening
to jordan has recent conversations with
yomi park and russell brand these are
all just fascinating fascinating
conversations go check it out right now
jordanharbinger.com start for some
episode recommendations or search for
the jordan harbinger show that's h a r b
is in boy i n is in nancy g e r on apple
podcast spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts go check it out right now
alrighty so
joe manchin essentially just ended
joe biden's giant dreams but here's the
thing
that may save joe biden in the long run
because if joe biden actually got built
back better and inflation continued to
spiral out of control and the economy
continued to stagnate
it just would not redown to jupiter's
benefit now i feel i still think that
the democrats get slacked in 2022
because they're going to have to own
whatever comes next and nothing great is
happening for the next year or so
inflation is going to last well into
next year at this point that is being
conceded by the federal reserve
the economy is not growing the way it is
supposed to grow the democrats have
created a box of their own making they
cannot get out of it with regard to
covet the coveted panic mentality that
they relied upon for world breaking
change has actually broken their world
but
adding on top of that a five trillion
dollar package would not have redounded
joe biden's benefit so manchin killing
it might counter-intuitively be actually
quite good for joe biden see it took
bill clinton the 1994 election before he
realized that hillary care and giant
capital gains tax increases that these
things were very unpopular with the
american people the way the american
people sounded off was by giving
republicans their first congressional
majority in three decades
well joe biden
he's getting the wake-up call early but
he's not getting it from a congressional
election he's getting it from a member
of his own party in the form of joe
manchin
nonetheless the democrats are really
really angry over all of this naturally
as you would expect them to be because
again the idea was that now that joe
biden was was in control they were going
to get the bernie sanders presidency
they were going to get exactly what they
had always wanted well no
no that that's not going to happen
anymore so bernie sanders is now
slamming joe manchin here is the
socialist old coot from vermont who's
now the thought leader of the democratic
party who's been defeated by as it turns
out a majority of the american
population let's not pretend that it's
joe manchin and kirsten cinema alone who
are standing against this bill because
it's not true 52 senators stand against
this bill a majority of the senate is
not a matter of minority controlling is
a matter of a majority controlling and
here's bernie sanders though who is
lamenting this as a as he
as he thinks fondly of stalin
i think he's gonna have a lot of
explaining to do to the people of west
virginia
to tell them why he doesn't have the
guts to take on the drug companies and
lower the cost of prescription drugs
why he is not prepared to expand home
health care west virginia is one of the
poorest states in this country you got
elderly people and disabling disabled
people who would like to stay at home
were forced into nursing homes he's
going to have to tell the people of west
virginia why he doesn't want to expand
medicare to cover dental hearing and
eyeglasses i i've been to west virginia
a number of times and it's a great state
beautiful people but it is a state that
is struggling
okay so i would just like to point out
here that bernie sanders would not be
elected dog catcher in west virginia so
bernie sanders giving advice to joe
manchin who's been elected as a blue
senator in a very red state repeatedly
is laughable
if if bernie sanders believes that his
agenda is so popular why wasn't he the
nominee in the first place and again i
will never get over the fact that joe
biden is such a fool that he was elected
as a moderate and then he swung to the
bernie sanders side of the aisle it's
totally crazy to me okay alexander
ocasio-cortez is also jumping into the
fray so she tweeted out when a handful
of us in the house warned this would
happen if democratic leaders gave
manchin everything he wanted first by
moving the infrastructure plan before
buildback better instead of passing it
together many ridiculed our position
maybe they'll believe us next time or
maybe people will just keep calling us
naive
either way we cannot accept no for an
answer democratic leadership including
but not limited to the president himself
and house democratic leadership wrote a
massive check on their credibility the
night of the biff vote in order to
secure the votes they needed promising
passage of build back better to every
member who brought up mansion they
personally promised they had a solution
and bill back better would pass it is
simply not an option for democratic
leaders to walk away from buildback
batter voting rights etc they must find
a way just as they promised they would
when you raise this inevitability some
of us don't have the luxury of giving up
we serve working middle class and poor
people we serve everyday workers getting
ripped off and immigrants and black
communities and queer kids needing
shelter we will not walk away from them
and leadership can't walk away from them
either people can be mad at mansion all
they want but we knew he would do this
months ago where we need answers heard
from are the leaders who promised a path
on buildback better if biff passed biden
and democratic leaders they chose to
move biff alone instead of with bill
back better not mansion so they need to
fix it
we as always says aoc are here to fight
for this agenda what matters most to us
is that it gets done but we cannot just
shrug our shoulders and accept this as
some charlie brown moment our entire
democracy is on the line so we need to
get back in there and get this bleep
done period
so
slay queen yeah go for it seriously go
for it the entire progressive wing of
the party is super mad that they even
got built the the infrastructure plan so
it seems that aoc is still committed to
the idea that if the progressives had
voted no on infrastructure and they had
held together buildback better and
infrastructure that manchin would have
voted for that
no he wouldn't dove literally the only
thing that joe manchin would have voted
for is the infrastructure plan he was
not going to vote for both the only way
possibly he might have voted for both is
if republicans were the ones obstruction
obstructing the infrastructure plan
right that was the romney logic
but
they weren't joe manchin was not going
to vote for a seven trillion dollar
package because aoc and illinois wanted
it these people are out of their minds
they they truly do seem to think that
like small boroughs in new york govern
the entire country
and that senators are not answerable to
their home states
and illinois omar joined the crew she
slammed mansion as well here is the
horrible congresswoman from minnesota
we all knew that uh senator manchin
couldn't be trusted um you know the the
excuses that he just made um i think are
a complete bull
um it is really disheartening uh to hear
him say that he has been trying to get
there for the people of west virginia um
because that's a complete lie there are
just so many things that you know the
people of west virginia desperately need
and we know that he is not
working on behalf of their interest and
i really am
just completely disappointed and
disgusted by his reasoning
well i mean i if the people of west
virginia don't love ilhan or omar i mean
wow i mean
when she speaks the people of west
virginia listen that is definitely a
state west virginia where ilhan omar i'm
sure is wildly popular her perspectives
are super popular in west virginia again
the delusional nature of progressives
who think they have a national program
as opposed to the reality of politics
which is you're always cobbling together
a coalition to do incremental things
that is most of politics and that it
turns out joe biden did not have a
mandate for anything remotely like this
it's amazing and they will continue
deluding themselves along these lines
the progressives which means that joe
biden should get with the program right
if he had any brains at all if he didn't
have mush for brains at this point which
i mean physically mush for brains then
he would probably be pushing for a
piecemeal approach to a lot of this
legislation but i don't know if he can
do it i don't know if joe biden can get
there he's so afraid of the progressive
wing because they're the most motivated
wing even though they represent a tiny
percentage of his party that he's going
to continue pushing this it's utterly
insane in a second we'll talk about joe
biden and the wild progressive wing that
has they're in the ascendants in the
democratic party but they're not getting
anything done we'll get to that in just
a moment first you know your gas prices
are too high they just they're really
really high right now you go to
california it's like five bucks a gallon
in some places i'm thrilled to introduce
an incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download that free get upside
app in the app store or google play
right now
use promo code shapiro get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
that app for free use promo code shapiro
get up to 50 cents per gallon cash back
on your first tank some people who drive
a lot are making as much as two to 300
bucks a month in cash back there's no
catch the cash back gets added directly
to your account you can cash out any
time to your bank account paypal or any
gift card for amazon and other brands so
if you freak out every time you go to
the pump because it's really expensive
why not get some money back with
getupside download that free get upside
app use promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your very
first tank of gas that is code shapiro
when you get that free get upside app
and use permaculture up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your first tank of
gas enough to 25 cents per gallon after
that okay so
the progressives continue to preach an
agenda that is just completely at odds
with the rest of the american public and
again i don't find that shocking aoc is
from the bluest part of blue state
america
sure is recruited by the justice
democrats to be like the bluest of the
blue aoc is not the shock the shock is
joe biden i mean aoc is constantly
spouting stuff that is completely
disconnected from reality for example
she said over the weekend that student
loan debt is immoral
in what way if i take a loan to spend
money on a thing and then i have to
repay the money that is not immoral you
know what's immoral
what's immoral is welshing on your deal
right that's immoral it's immoral to to
walk back
a a loan and try to get out of it that's
immoral but here is aoc claiming that
apparently it's moral to steal money
from people i mean of course she thinks
this she's a socialist
there is also the the case of just
millions of people in the united states
that already went to college and they
were saddled with a lot of unethical uh
and immoral immorally kind of
created student loan debt and so this is
a bucket of folks where if we lower the
price of college they are still stuck
with huge amounts of student loan debt
did someone put a gun to their heads
when they took out that debt to study
lesbian dance theory at wellesley
[Music]
this is the agenda by the way aoc says
that we should abolish the senate her
solution to joe manchin is that we
should just get rid of the senate of the
united states don't worry they're not
radicals they're not radicals they're
just progressives who like to think in a
different way
there are certain institutions since the
founding of the united states that are
fundamentally undemocratic the united
states senate is one such example
now we elect our senators by popular
vote that is a democratic
part that is a democratic function
there are some states
like for example in georgia and in texas
where the right to vote is under attack
and that is fundamentally undemocratic
but what makes the senate but that
affects everybody
and all seats but what makes the senate
fundamentally undemocratic is that it
gives
small groups of people
the same amount of power
as
massive groups of people
and that is not democratic at all
okay so
so
our system was structured for gridlock
this is the whole point progressives
hate our system because because
progressives believe that our system
should be ripped down in favor of a
left-wing dictatorship i mean that's
essentially what they believe that as
long as they can command a majority of
50 plus one they should be able to ram
down on americans whatever right
violating policy they feel is necessary
that day i mean here again aoc is the
thought leader guys by the way i think
that there's a serious shot that if joe
biden plots is before 2024 or if he just
doesn't run
bernie's gonna need an heir you really
think that she wouldn't run some sort of
quixotic presidential campaign she
absolutely would she raised more money
than anybody else on the left
she's the new bernie say here here's aoc
pushing uh pushing crt as well okay
critical race theory
i think one of the things that
has been almost like difficult for me
personally
in
working in congress is
seeing
how
different
the
you know not only the rest of the
country is because that diversity is
great it's not that it's different
but it's how accepting of racism
a lot of other communities are there was
recently this debate in virginia for
example
that people don't want their kids really
learning about racism or the history of
racism in the united states they call
this critical race theory
no that of course you're completely
misconstrued i'm sorry no matter how
large her glasses get she's still going
to be an idiot her glasses seem to
increase exponentially each time she is
on a screen like they started off as
spectacles and now they are just giant
hubble telescopes but in any case
in any case
the whole thing is is very okay but
here's the thing we can make fun of aoc
all we want but joe biden decided to
take his cues from the swing of the
party that's the peril never get over
why why okay he's still doing this right
over the weekend joe biden slurring his
way through yet another
discombobulated speech suggested that
black people don't have lawyers i don't
know what he's talking about i'm very
well aware of black people who not only
have lawyers but are lawyers
turns out lots of black people have
lawyers like what is he what is he even
talking about i think he's living still
like in 1911 or something here we go
we learned there's no difference between
a black entrepreneur and a white
entrepreneur and success
except the black entrepreneur usually
doesn't have a lawyer
usually doesn't have someone who is
going to be there an accountant to get
it all set up their idea
is as profound
but the help
is missing
his random anger is very strange he'll
do speeches and then he just idea it's
like what do you whoa
dude
yeah i have a joke here i won't say in
any case uh joe biden and then of course
he continues along the aoc lines that
there's sinister voter suppression going
on remember this guy is the great uniter
he's speaking at a historically black
college and university commencement here
and uh he is talking about sinister
voter suppression this is the same guy
who said mitt romney wanted to put black
people back in chains so so captain
uniting over here is not very uniting i
noticed
this new sinister combination of voter
suppression
election
election subversion it's un-american
it's undemocratic and sadly it is
unprecedented since reconstruction
vice president harris is leading the
efforts for us but on the anniversary of
bloody sunday
i directed every single federal agency
in the united states government to
promote access to voting and each agency
is heading
and heeding the call
okay so it's it's the worst situation on
voting in the united states since
reconstruction
you there was like a hundred year period
after the civil war in which
there was overt
prevention of black people from voting
in the united states like overt not
covert overt
legal segregation was a regime that
dominated about half the united states
for a century job but again he's
embraced the full-scale left-wing
radical agenda and so joe manchin you
know it was it was a dose of reality and
here's the thing i think democrats are
about to be hit by reality on virtually
every front i think they're getting hit
by reality on covet as well i think
omicron is about to demonstrate some
reality up close and personal you can
start to see reality dawning on them
that's a very awkward feeling for them
we'll get to that in just one moment
first
let's talk about the fact that you as a
responsible person need life insurance i
mean let's say that you're responsible
each and every year for delivering
literally hundreds of millions of
presidents around the globe are you
getting your slay every single year and
you you're flying over the rooftops and
you land on some top somebody's house
you're gonna pop down the chimney you're
gonna leave some gifts and then some
weird guy down there on the lawn starts
yelling at you you look down at him for
just a second you lose your footing you
start sliding it down the roof well as
you fall off the gutter it occurs to you
man i really should have gotten some
life insurance before tim allen becomes
santa claus and replaces me well if you
want life insurance there's only one
great place to get a policy genius
policygenius.com shapiro allows you to
get life insurance by answering a few
questions about yourself in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius their license experts will
help you understand your options and
apply for a policy the policy genius
team works for you not the insurance
companies you can trust them to offer
unbiased help and advocate for you at
every step until you are covered policy
genius does not add on extra fees or
sell your information to third parties
they have thousands of five star reviews
across trustpilot and google since 2014
policy genius has helped over 30 million
people shop for insurance head on over
to policygenius.com slash appeal get
your free life insurance quotes see how
much you could save the policygenius.com
shapiropolicygenius.com
shapiro alrighty before we get to the
latest on covid where panic has broken
out everywhere for no apparent reason
first let me tell you about a brand new
show we've got out right now it's called
the search and the reason it's called
the search is it really is about a
search for truth and meaning it is i sit
down basically with my most interesting
friends because thank god i live a
pretty awesome life where i get to talk
with interesting people who are my
friends almost every day
and we sit down for coffee and just hang
out and i decided i want to let you in
on some of those conversations so if you
want to see a fly on the wall
conversation between me and jordan
peterson we just went to a coffee shop
and we just talked about what was on our
minds it's pretty spectacular it's
really great stuff it's a way that you
haven't seen jordan or me before the
first episode is available right now at
dailywire.com it's called the search
we're gonna be doing more with jordan in
the future i'm really excited about it
head on over right now to dailywire.com
and subscribe to get access to the
search it's one of our most trafficked
pieces of content ever and there's a
reason why also candace owens doesn't
hold back that's why the daily wires
sent her to mar-a-lago to interview one
of the most censored people in america
of course president trump no question
was off the table they discussed
everything from the potential for
another presidential run in 2024 to why
donald trump did not pardon
whistleblowers and also what he really
thinks about alec baldwin who of course
played him on snl the interview is
fascinating it streams tomorrow 9pm
eastern 8 pm central only at
dailywire.com if you're not a member yet
now is the time to join if you love
candace's stuff head on over to
yesweekcanvas.com to pick up some
awesome and candace merch plus the daily
wire is now making it easier to listen
to all of our content on the go with our
launch of listen which means you'll now
be able to listen to all your favorite
daily our content on the website and in
the dw app listen it's here to make
soaking up our content as convenient as
possible with a limited ad audio
experience whether it's catching morning
wire with a morning cup of coffee taking
in the latest hot takes from your
favorite hose or exploring or growing at
radio theater you'll get all the content
you love and if you get interrupted no
worries you can pick up right where you
left off with continue listening and
that's not all we made sure it's
available to members and non-members so
get ready to listen because we've got a
lot to say you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so meanwhile the democrats have
boxed themselves since they boxed
themselves on policy because they
started following the aoc progressive
policy agenda the bernie sanders agenda
and they didn't have the support for it
and they really boxed themselves in
uncovered because their take on covet is
what is destroying the economy their
take on covet is leading to more opioid
deaths their take on covet is leading to
depression across broad swathes of the
american population because their take
on covet is completely disconnected from
reality the reality was always was
always that elderly people people in
nursing homes people with pre-existing
conditions were highly vulnerable to
covid and that everybody else was maybe
a little tiny bit vulnerable to covet
and if you were really young you weren't
vulnerable to clovener at all that was
always the logic always and now
as we have a new variant that is way
more transmissible than delta and
apparently way less deadly than delta
they can't let go of the idea that they
promulgated that kovid was a thing
government could could handle and
government could get rid of and so even
to acknowledge that covet has become
endemic
is it's almost a blind spot for them
they can't they can never acknowledge it
instead they've sunk into an endless
malaise
and so
chris chaliza
right has a piece over at cnn and it is
so insanely delusional it really is
listen to this okay it's called why my
coveted anxiety is spiking now all these
months later
the answer is because you refuse to
understand basic realities about life i
mean that's the real answer
but there's been an embedded sense of
panic and doom that democrats have
promulgated as the essence of virtue
they're essentially the same as people
who are walking around
in the 13th century with chanting that
the end was near repent
but what you're supposed to repent too
is basically the dominance of government
it is a religious perspective at this
point
okay i've talked before about fear of
god right the idea of of yurochimayum in
hebrew fear these peoples believe that
if they fear a coveted enough it will
leave them alone is totally crazy here's
chris chaliza i remember the moment
distinctly it was thanksgiving we my
wife kids and mom were at my college
friend's house with his family everyone
was vaccinated we had all taken rapid
tests that morning to make sure it was
safe to celebrate together so first of
all
you were vaccinated so why are you even
taking the rapid test who cares who
cares even if you gave it to each other
you're gonna be fine because the
vaccinations are super effective and you
can't do anything about it anyway
because welcome to life but here's what
he says that was the last day i felt
relatively unworried about covet 19.
since the word omicron entered our
lexicon every day has been filled with
varying levels of stress really has it
that seems like a you problem to me i'll
be honest with you if you're vast and
you're sitting around panicked about oh
macron
i think that what you actually need is
not a vaccine you need another type of
medication you need an antidepressant or
maybe an anti-anxiety
medication
but
if you're sitting around like panicked
about this stuff i don't and you're vast
i don't know what's wrong with you i
can't i've got nothing for you except a
psychiatrist number
christian lisa says
there's the near daily note from the
boys school about students testing
positive and the measure is being put in
place to contain it okay and
and
so what your kids will be fine
kids are not getting seriously ill from
kovid
the numbers on children who have died
from covet i'm not going to stop
repeating it because it remains true the
number of kids who have died who are
healthy before kovid who died of covid
in the united states under the age of 18
is still below
20. there's a parade of headlines that
suggest says chris chalisa omicron is on
the march in europe and that a surge is
inevitable in the united states right
but it's a surge of cases so who cares
who cares
there's a surge of cases every year
around this time in the cold in the
common cold do we care
have you ever i i don't even have any
idea how many people every year are
diagnosed with the common cold
you don't even go to the doctor no one
goes to the doctor for the common cold
because it's so common that is literally
why it is called the common cold
but chris chaliza's panicked he says
there are invites to christmas parties
and for the kids to attend sleepovers
and play dates and holiday trips and a
million and one other things that
require my wife and me to play the role
of public health experts
hyperventilation get him a paper bag
here's the problem says chris chaliza
i'm not a public health expert or
anything close to it in fact because of
a long battle with health anxiety and
compulsive behavior i'm a terrible
person to be tasked with making these
daily calls he is begging to be ruled
and this is so many people now they have
put all their faith in a government that
cannot solve the problem but they
require a ruler they want a ruler i
can't be i can't be han
i can't handle these these particular
conversations or these decisions
okay just cause you can't doesn't mean
that i can't i am perfectly happy to
make these decisions with my family so
are the vast majority of americans by
the way i can make this decision with my
parents with my kids with my wife i can
make all these decisions myself i don't
need the great god of dr anthony fauci
descending from on high to explain
what's what's going on with everything
with covet and omicron melanoma
the hell is wrong with you people get a
grip
chris chaliza says more than 20 months
into this nightmare more than a year
after the first vaccine was administered
more than eight hundred thousand deaths
later it seems there is no end in sight
really because the end was in sight
literally the day that i got my second
dose once i got my second dose and once
it kicked in the end was not only inside
it was over for me i have not worried
for one iota of one moment since that
day you know why because i actually
follow the data that's why
but says chris shaliza i feel
emotionally raw everything from anger to
exhaustion to resignation sits heavier
on me now than it did at that
thanksgiving dinner a few weeks ago i'm
exhausted from the constant not knowing
each new day feels like it brings a
darkening prediction of what the future
holds and i'm tired he's citing
deuteronomy now it's like every night
you go to bed thinking that you wish it
were the morning and then every morning
you wish it were the prior night because
things just get worse and worse i'm a
creature of habits as christianiza i
love knowing what the next day will
bring with the pandemic it feels like
the situation is changing by the hour
i'm resigned to the fact none of this is
going away soon the idea that coveted
will be in the rear view mirror by march
feels at this point quaint i've watched
the goal post for the end of the
pandemic move so many times i can't even
remember where they were a month ago
so what leftist politicians and what the
media have done is they have turned
everybody into the rat in the experiment
and so there's a very famous rat
experiment where rats were were fed
pellets every time they hit a button
and then
rats were electro shocked sometimes when
they hit the button
well it was only like every fourth time
but what the rats started to do they
wouldn't learn the pattern they would
just stay away from the button until
they starved that is what you have done
with these these people this is what
government and the media have done
you've scared people so crapless that
they are afraid of doing anything even
when the risk is incredibly low
you have enervated them you've turned
them into pathetic muelling specimens
says chris chiliza
this has always been one of my favorite
times of the year now it's filled with
dread and foreboding all i know is it's
been a long december and i need to find
reasons to believe that next year is
something i can look forward to
so what you're going to you're just
going to wait on an anthony factory to
tell you okay so the reason that i'm so
scornful of all of this is because i
look at the stats so let me show you
some statistics
here are some statistics these are
statistics from the united kingdom okay
these are the case stats
so as of july there are very very few
cases in the united kingdom of covid 19
as of this as of this june july and then
it spiked in july so there are almost 50
000 cases right that was the delta wave
and then it sank back down below 30 000
cases a day as of like august and sort
of gradually rose kind of some ups and
some downs and then
in about november
huge spike huge spike in cases
higher than it's ever been spiking cases
from maybe 35 000 cases a day all the
way up to well over 70 000 cases a day
this is the seven day rolling average
not not the day-to-day number right the
seven-day rolling average okay so it
more than doubled over the course of the
last month
so we are now a month out what you would
expect is that the deaths would start to
increase right uh here are the death
stats from the uk
notice something
complete disconnect go back to the last
chart for a second okay what you'll see
in the last chart is that there was a
big spike in november particularly right
november of 2020 right in november of
2020 around the end of november there's
a big spike in cases all the way up to
about 60 000 cases a day now go to the
other chart for a second if you go to
the other chart what you'll see is that
about two weeks later
right two to four weeks later huge spike
in deaths
because that's what you expect
when covet hits there's a huge increase
in cases and then there is a huge spike
in hospitalizations and deaths thanks to
the vaccines because the uk was heavily
vaccinated there is no such spike in
june july right what you see is like a
slight increase you know it increases
from zero a day in early june
all the way go back one it increases
from zero day into early june to a
little under 200 a day and it kind of
stays there all the way throughout the
panama because the vaccines now you have
this huge vast mass spike
any increase in deaths no deaths right
now in the united kingdom seven-day
rolling average is actually lower now
than it was about a week ago
okay so is that only the uk where
they've seen a massive spike no it turns
out it is not only the uk here is south
africa
so south africa has had three very clear
waves this is the fourth very clear wave
okay and this this wave is enormous they
went from basically zero cases a day in
mid-november to
essentially 30 000 cases a day as of
today and that started solidly a month
ago
started three weeks to a month ago here
are the death stats from south africa
oh look there's no spike in death at all
right it's the same super low rate
where's the spike okay if you think it's
just over in south africa where this
thing started or in the uk i bring new
york okay so here's new york new york
has seen a massive spike again mass
mandates vaccines massive spiking cases
right they're all the way down well
below 5 000 cases a day at the beginning
of november and then it started to spike
and now they're up to almost 15 000
cases a day in the seven day rolling
average this is the new york times
numbers hey here's their deaths this is
new york
and new york state notice something this
is the city-wide deaths in new york okay
same rate
almost none
you know why because omicron is not
nearly as deadly as delta this is
evidenced by south africa
the last wave in south africa about
three weeks out from the from that wave
19 hospitalization rate this time 1.7
hospitalization rate
lab studies are showing that omicron is
residing
in the upper airways it is not going
down to the lungs which means no lung
damage which means people aren't dying
and yet we are told that we must panic
this is why chris chiliz is panicking
like a little baby he's crying like a
small baby
so democrats are faced with a problem
here and the problem is they've told you
that you were supposed to panic over
every variant the variants were the
reason why we needed the spending the
variance were the reason why you had to
trust the government and instead of
recognizing the reality which is that
the virus kind of solved itself okay
omicron kind of solves everything and
because if omicron is super contagious
and super not deadly and it provides
essentially a level of immunity to a lot
of people who have not had it yet if
you're an unvaxed person you want
omicron way worse than you want delta
you don't want delta you want omicron if
you're going to get infected
but this gives democrats the
heebie-jeebies because because
they have no control over it
right they have no control over the
common cold and so this scares the hell
out of them and so they're now
completely bifurcated right there
they're two minds and they can't handle
the cognitive dissonance on the one hand
lock everything down omicron's gonna
kill us all the government's the only
thing that can save us it's all the
stupid on backs and other and on the
other hand they're like well i mean
people really do want their schools open
so a bunch of people on the left are now
getting diagnosed with covid which is
fine if you've got a breakthrough case
because you were vast or because you had
natural immunity
and turns out you have a cold who cares
no one
but but democrats are are panicking
about this anyway so on the one hand
they're panicking about it because oh my
god oh my god everyone's gonna die it's
gonna be terrible this is why you have
to give us control give us controls and
on the other hand when they get covered
they kind of don't want to do all the
things they've been telling everybody
else to do so suddenly brian stelter at
cnn has flipped 180 degrees and he's
talking about the evils of shutting down
schools
when they're covered outbreaks um yeah
brian some of us have been saying this
all along dude
we collectively took action to protect
the elderly in 2020. now shouldn't we be
doing more to protect children
by letting them live normal lives
are we really going to let the kids
suffer even more
welcome to the club brian stelter i mean
like seriously i'm glad you're here but
i'm noticing that most of the people on
the left are only getting in line with
the fact that life has to get back to
some semblance of normal once it's
starting affected them
when it was all red states then they're
like all those evil red states and
they're they're uptight so then new york
gets hit vermont gets it all these
heavily vac states are getting hit cause
guess what when people go inside they
pass kovid
duh
and now all of a sudden say well maybe
we've gone too far here guys maybe we've
gone too far but they can't let it go
and so they're ping-ponging between we
can never let this go grip it harder
grip it harder kill the bird and on the
other hand we must let the bird live
release the dove right like they can't
get over it and so you've got this
bizarre ping-pong effect for for the
democratic party should we panic should
we not panic what do we do
and they have no clue at the same time
you got brian stelter saying that kids
should be in school cnn is shutting into
offices because of the covet 19 spike
it's totally insane
so this sort of bifurcation is not going
to end the bifurcation for the
democratic party is not going to end
despite the fact that again omicron
should not be freaking everybody out it
should not
even the articles that are headlined
in a panic driven way when you read down
into the data they're not that scary for
example there's a piece in the wall
street journal says hospitals are
strained even before oh macron hits
intensive care units in many cities are
at close
or are at or close to full capacity due
to patients with serious non-coveted
diseases
so wait
you're telling me i'm supposed to worry
about omicron because there are a lot of
people with
with other diseases that have nothing to
do with covid
okay according to the wall street
journal article buried down in this
article excess deaths are a measure of
how many people lost their lives above
an average from prior years hospital
strain could be one reason for results
researchers not involved in the study
said another factor may be people who
put off care seeking care during the
pandemic
out of fear of an action so in other
words one of the reasons you're seeing
an icu strain right now is because
everybody didn't go to the hospital and
then they thought it was safe to go to
the hospital so everybody went to the
hospital at the same time that ain't
about omicron that ain't even about
delta that's about the lockdowns
but we're supposed to panic it's very
important that we panic
by the way here are the actual stats
from the wall street journal 60
of adult icu patients in cities with
icus at least 90 full do not have
coveted infections
do not the same about kovid
is about everything else it's about you
delayed everybody's care for a year and
then everybody showed up at the same
time
but democrats can't get like they're all
over the place on this it's amazing to
watch they truly are all over the place
on this
take for example new york city so in new
york city bill de blasio has put down a
a mandate that is supposed to take
effect about four days before he leaves
office and that mandate is that everyone
in the city has to be vast or you're not
allowed to work in the city i know
business owners in new york are freaking
out over this because guess what there's
a labor shortage right now and now
you're asking people to fire their
workers or find them like a thousand
dollars per incident
what is eric adams going to do the
incoming mayor of new york now we were
told that eric adams was going to be a
moderate he was going to come in he was
going to repudiate a lot of the de
blasio legacy he doesn't sound like much
of a moderate with regard to covid does
he here he was on cnn over the weekend
we do an amazing job we're looking at
those areas where we have large
outbreaks we're
temporarily shutting down the schools in
those areas
i think it's smart it's a great way to
go and we're going to continue to do
that this is a moving target and we need
to be clear on that
by the way i have some doubts about uh
the new mayor of new york considering
that he literally has said to the new
york times that the number one skill he
looks for in his administration is wait
for it wait for it emotional
intelligence
man oh man if the people like you know
it's a thing that i don't look for as
like a high
as a high resume item here at the daily
wire emotional intelligence because
there's no way to quantify that like you
want people to get along with other
people but if that's your number one
criteria
yeah good good luck with that emotional
intelligence anyway
the the complete gap in how democrats
are thinking about this thing is leading
to all sorts of bizarre shifts in
messaging so over the weekend cnn
announced that the biden administration
would be eyeing a potentially stark
shift in messaging around ending the
pandemic
quote
sitting at the head of a long conference
table surrounded by top members of his
coveted response team biden listened
intently as the officials laid out the
contours of a looming coveted surge
they could accelerate rapidly swamp
hotels and send the country into another
bleak winter
yet biden's team also came to the
evergreen bedecked roosevelt room with
potentially more positive news
many of those cases will remain mild or
even asymptomatic in vaccinated people
particularly those who've gotten booster
shots
so biden is uh is is trying to scare the
unvacs into vaccine
and they're trying to shift into
focusing on severity
rather than focusing on case numbers
which is what some of us have been
urging the entire damned time no one
cares about case numbers severity is the
only thing that matters
but by the way if you mention that let
me just point this out if you mention
that anywhere during the pandemic we
should focus on severity hospitalization
and death not case counts
this administration actively tried to
smear people who said this actively
over the weekend the daily mail
reported on emails between anthony fauci
and the head of the nih francis collins
you know the idiot who plays guitar and
warm warbles about some day
after the pandemic that that idiot
apparently these idiots were writing
each other emails talking about the
great barrington declaration the great
barrington declaration
is a declaration by a bunch of
epidemiologists including dr j
bhattacharya from stanford
who
suggested that we shield the vulnerable
and allow everybody else to live their
lives
apparently
fauci and and the head of the nih
colluded on a way to discredit that
alternative plan to deal with covid
in an october 8th email from collins to
fauci the head of the nih called the
great barrington declaration the work of
three fringe epidemiologists that seem
to be getting a lot of attention
collins adequate there needs to be a
quick and devastating published takedown
of its premises i don't see anything
like that online yet is it underway
later in the day fauci sent collins a
wired op-ed that refuted the notion of
herd immunity stopping the pandemic
collins then sent vouching op-ed in the
nation also trashing the great
barrington declaration a few days later
collins emailed faucio washington post
op-ed he was quoted in headlined
proposal to hasten herd immunity to the
coronavirus grabs white house attention
but appall's top scientists
collins said my quotes are accurate but
will not be be appreciated in the trump
white house
voucher responded they are too busy with
other things to worry about this what
you said was entirely correct
so they basically conspired in order to
attack the great barrington declaration
at no point did they actually explain
why the great barrington declaration was
wrong the great barrington declaration
did not suggest that quote-unquote herd
immunity was the solution they suggested
that herd immunity is the only thing
ever
that generates the end of widespread
pandemics right the herd immunity either
comes via vaccines or it comes via
natural immunity and they suggested that
if you let young healthy people work it
was not going to be the end of the world
and you should shield the vulnerable but
francis collins and anthony fauci spent
their time trying to destroy the authors
of this declaration now they're of
course embracing its exact same premises
well you know if you get a case and it
ain't that bad it's not that bad yeah we
know guys but you tried to destroy
everybody who said this a year ago
here is francis collins who is when he's
not playing guitar is appearing on bret
bear trying to explain that hundreds of
thousands of people would have died if
we'd listen to the great barrington
declaration i hate to break it to you
sir more people have died under joe
biden than died under donald trump
what was being proposed there was
basically saying let's not worry about
mitigation let's just let this virus rip
this of course before we had vaccines
and basically these i will call them
french epitheliologists who really did
not have the credentials to be making
such a grand sweeping statement we're
saying just let the virus run through
the population and eventually then
everybody will have had it and we'll be
okay hundreds of thousands of people
would have died if we had followed that
strategy
um well hundreds of thousands of people
have died following your strategy and
tens of thousands more young people have
died of opioid
overdoses because of your strategy
but again they have to maintain the fact
that they were not wrong this whole time
they were wrong the whole time this is
why they are attached to the idea they
can still crush omicron they can't
omicron is 70 times it's transmissible
it's a common cold we're all going to
get it it doesn't matter i'm vexed i'm
going to get it okay i'm just working
under that assumption and for nearly
everyone it is going to be a mild cold
and everyone knows it
but they can't let go of it so now
they're trying they're struggling for a
new message so what is their new message
so one of the new messages pushed by
jeff zenz who's one of their their covet
advisors is the unvaccinated are all
going to die and everyone else is going
to be okay so if you just listen to us
you'll be fine now here's the thing
that was more true at delta than it is
of omicron
it's hard to break it to you omicron is
way less deadly than delta by all
available data which suggests that if
you are unvaxed for delta and you
weren't worried about delta you should
be about one-tenth as worried about
omicron and yet they're still trying to
scare the crap out of people
here is uh here is jeff zens
basically
trying to scare the living hell out of
the unvaccine suggest also of course
that they're morally insufficient in
some way which is which is odd
considering that again the vast can pass
this too so really the danger is to you
if you decide to get not vaxxed at all
you're the one who's decided to undergo
that danger that's kind of your business
but here's jeff sense trying to uh this
is pretty despicable stuff here
we are intent on not letting omicron
disrupt work in school for the
vaccinated
you've done the right thing and we will
get through this
for the unvaccinated
you're looking at a winter of severe
illness and death
for yourselves your families and the
hospitals you may soon overwhelm
um wow
so so just to get this straight they're
gonna make sure that you're safe and
good if you're vaccinated if you're
unvaccinated prepare to die
you'll kill my father prepare to die
anthony fauci is doing the same thing
and it's unclear exactly what he's
promoting at this point because they
don't have any plan their only plan is
to scare the living daylights out of you
while pretending they know what they're
doing so here's anthony fatchy saying
seven different things a bunch of
different ways running around like
kermit the frog with his hands flailing
in the air well on jake tapper harry was
saying we're going to see unfortunately
we'll see record levels of positives
question why is it unfortunate if
somebody gets a cold and now has
immunity to other forms of the virus why
is that i'm confused here's anthony
fauci
where is the pandemic headed right now
do you expect new record high numbers
for cases and what about
hospitalizations and deaths
well unfortunately jake i think that
that is going to happen uh we are going
to see a significant stress
in some regions of the country on the
hospital system particularly in those
areas where you have a low level of
vaccination which is one of the reasons
why
we continue to stress the importance of
getting those unvaccinated people
vaccinated
ken i'm very much in favor of the
vaccines
but omicron is not going to act like
delta i don't know why he won't talk
about this
then then fouch is like by the way
vaccines aren't the answer to everything
but you just said they they kind of were
i mean i've been told by jeff's sentence
that my life will be fully back to
normal if i get vaccinated except that
you keep shutting down cities where
everyone is vaccinated here's anthony
fauci explaining to you what you need to
do which is triple mask quadruple mask
octuple mask your entire head should be
covered in masks you should have masks
far beyond your death you should be
masking unborn children
and just to prevent them from from
getting covered before they're aborted
you should definitely mask the unborn
children also the dead
just enter your relatives bring them up
from the ground and and please mask them
because they might die from from be it
from the covid after being dead for 20
years here we go
people think that vaccine is the answer
to everything
we can't do it without vaccines jake but
we can do a lot more with other things
and testing for example both yourself
and your family when you're getting
ready to do something go out into the
community or when you're going to have
people over your own house and that's
the reason why
we're stressing and part of the
president's winter plan is expanding
greatly the availability of testing for
people
testing truly testing that's gonna
that's gonna do it you know how many
people who are asymptomatic are testing
in fact it's so bad that the nfl just
suspended testing the asymptomatic
because they're not idiots and they
don't want to shut down their entire
league
asymptomatic testing is the dumbest
thing though by the way you can't even
get tess right now because this
administration's done a crappy job with
the testing you're going to test your
way out of the common cold
but falci continues with it then he's
like well mate okay so vaccines are not
the answer
maybe testing is the answer but
testing's not the answer maybe boosters
are the answers let's go let's what's
behind door number three dr fauci
the booster that i spoke about at the
press conference today really does bring
up the level
of the protection to a quite high level
and that's the reason why
we are really encouraging very strongly
that when you're eligible for a boost to
get boosted because the data i showed
indicated that particularly with omicron
that the level of protection goes really
rather low in a in a in a range that may
not be as protective as we'd like but
yet when you get that boost
it goes right up there
okay well that's actually not what the
data shows but the data shows that
boosters particularly for the elderly
are worthwhile with regard to delta
because you want your antibody levels
high again but all the boosters do is
increase your answer body level your
b-cell and t-cell immunity still exist
again he doesn't even bother with b-cell
and cell immunity he doesn't even
explain when you explain when he talks
about vaccine protection is he talking
about infection or is he talking about
hospitalization and death he doesn't
make clear what the hell he's talking
about
what he's really talking about there is
infection he's not talking about
hospitalization and death because the
two two-dose vaccine is still for nearly
everyone under the age of 65 highly
protected against hospitalization and
death
but now so now just just to get this
straight yesterday he suggested vaccines
are the answer vaccines are not the
answer to everything
we need boosters
also we need to mask forever
he literally said yesterday we're gonna
mask forever on airplanes for the rest
of time we're gonna mask on airplanes
for the rest of time
are we gonna get to the point where we
won't have to wear masks on airplanes
i don't think so i think when you're
dealing with a closed space even though
the filtration is good
that you want to go that extra step when
you have people you know you get a
flight from washington to san francisco
it's a well over a five-hour flight
even though you have a good filtration
system i still believe that masks are a
prudent thing to do and we should be
doing it okay this is new york
okay you know what new york has
vax mandates mask mandates you noticing
something about that case count right
there you notice that weird it looks
exactly like case counts everywhere else
but anthony fauci has a solution okay so
here is the deal if you guys wish to
live in this paranoia of your own making
where you worry every day like chris
chaliza does of cnn you just sit around
worrying fine live that way but you
don't get to dictate that to the rest of
us that our lives ought to be miserable
i'm not going to listen to you because i
don't think that you have any
relationships with the data i don't
think you care about the data i think
you've created a reality in your head
where you guys are morally superior for
having listened to the government even
though the governmental actors we're not
providing you good data and we're mainly
lying to you
so if you want to live that way fine
live that way but guess what we'll just
take everyone who earns from your state
we'll take them down here in florida
we'll take them in georgia we'll take
them in texas we'll take them in
kentucky we'll take them in tennessee
we'll take them everywhere
you want to send all of your productive
risk-seeking or at least non-crazily
risk-averse people
and send them down here fine we'll take
all of them
because this is what you've created for
yourselves
you've created a bunch of people who
cower in fear every time one of you
makes a moronic anti-data statement
eventually what's going to happen of
course is that they'll let up eventually
they'll let up and they'll realize
they're miserable and then they'll be
like oh well the pandemic is over great
job us we ended it
but not yet not yet because they can't
bring themselves to do it just quite yet
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content by
the way as i've been talking about we
should not be complying with all of this
crap right all this stuff is crap you
shouldn't be complying if you wish to
fight back go to dailywire.com do not
comply we're very very close to a
million signatures that is our goal we
want to get there by christmas we're
only a few thousand signatures away so
head on over to dailywire.com
do not comply in the meantime we'll be
back with an additional hour of content
later today also check out our newest
podcast morning wire on today's episode
they report closing arguments in the
gislane maxwell case and google's strict
vax mandates that episode is available
right now on apple spotify or wherever
you listen to podcast make sure to tune
in i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire
on today's episode senator manchin kills
biden's build back better act
closing arguments in the galain maxwell
trial begin and google imposes strict
vaccine mandates
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire